thanks so much i think it's isla by the
way it's going to take us like six weeks
before you guys get her name right
anyway richard
richard
talking about pronunciation
we have been careers and i hate to say
it about the pronunciation of your last
name tell us definitively as we always
say rapport uh and sometimes rapport
what how is your last name
pronounced i think you guys are doing
pretty well i mean it's rapport in
hungarian like just as a whole thing but
rapport with the t at the end yep okay
guys you got it get it without it report
it there you go okay well richard report
wit coming in third place you started
off slow
nevertheless it has been a crazy event
like up and down and
nuts how do you feel about your third
place finish uh yeah
sadly at the end it was mostly down um
well you know the first day of blitz
went really badly for me i mean i mean
minus minus two but it felt like you
know minus nine i don't know like i
really played off
uh chess and today i've i managed kind
of to pull myself together so but i am
kind of disappointed you know the the
two games with fight which i lost
towards the end where none of them was
really necessary of course i won some
games by luck as well but but it's you
know very different when you're um
playing the games and you feel it you
know you feel the flow let's say going
and then
just for kind of no reason i throw out a
few points which would make the
tournament uh much more interesting yeah
we did see you get a gift from chakriar
that was
yeah that's nasty yeah but you know
these kings indian positions for a few
seconds they are like much more trickier
let's say than this i don't know one
against the two against one looking game
which i lost time in
seconds so i figured this is blitz and
two seconds increments i mean you can uh
take some some risks yeah at the time
when it comes to attacking looking i
think people are just you know going to
blunder eventually just the question is
who will blunder last year
is there anything in the back of your
mind what might have been if you had
actually gotten a chance to play in
bucharest
um
you know not really i mean i guess it
should be there but i'm just you know
that kind of person i don't like to you
know beat myself up on the past on
things which i have basically no power
and influencing it so i'm like okay this
happened i will play the singfield club
next i'm looking very much forward to it
uh this event was also you know success
i mean compared to paris uh just clearly
an improvement for me so i'm just
generally happy and i'm no regrets yeah
absolutely those are the best words you
could possibly say i don't think i can
improve on it so i'm not going to ask
you any more questions we're looking
forward to seeing you do a fine
performance in the singing field cup
thanks richard our congratulations we
think you had a wonderful performance we
really enjoyed your games good luck in
the sink field cup
and of course that is going to be coming
up very soon